merci d'avoir accepté ce meeting donc ça
déjà
c'est pas un meeting ce là vous avez
frappé à ma porte vous est entré sans
aucune raison valable et où vous êtes et
si on en est là voilà bon quand vous
êtes observateur ça moi j'aime bien les
gens observateurs j'adore donc déjà en
train de collecter est la vraie question
c'est quoi la vraie question c'est est
ce qu'on ferait pas un festival dans un
château acteurs du morisien c'est pas ça
la vraie question la vraie question
c'est qu'est ce que vous foutez dans mon
bureau donc visiblement tout le monde
dit 'tiens par les mêmes vraie question
1 est-ce que c'est le débat non la 2è
reg question c'est c'est quoi château
festival l'humoriste moi je pensais le
bolide et je pense vous devriez dire oui
et on devrait pas perdre plus de temps
quoi ça ne va pas du tout et tout le
monde a dit oui déjà bon vous savez ce
qu'il tente là c'est que vous preniez
votre corps l'âme ou comme une algue
avec votre physique de calamar qui
fument et vous cachiez vous mettiez
bosser
mais je me bats
oui je me voyais je me casse oui oui
vous serez pas déçus pour me faire
confiance et bauchi vous barrer la
serbie temps
vous serez pas déçus
ça me casse toi bon il nous reste plus
que le château les humoristes mettait
directement de bd oui mais toi tu
comprends rien au business toi les gens
aujourd'hui 18 que quand tout le monde a
dit oui donc l'objectif c'est d'inventer
des wii jusqu'à ce que telle est vrai
oui donc là ce que tu vas me faire tu
vas prendre le moment où moi je demande
au patron de canal s'il veut un festival
dans la chatte avec des humoristes tu va
m'enlever le moment au milieu là où il
hésite un peu et après juste après tu
colles son ouïe et sème le faut pour
demain parce que moi demain j'ai des
coups de fil pour tout ce qui est
logistique tout ça ok qu'est ce qu'on
ferait pas un festival dans un château
lecteurs dû mourir oui oui oui oui oui
oui vous serez pas déçus je vais me
faire confiance qu'est-ce que tu
comprends pas dans la phrase canal+ a
dit oui et ben voilà donc tu m'envoies
une scène des micros des lumières de
quoi faire un festival et puis c'est
tout et bah houba houba où je vais te
dire deux mois 48 heures je te donne
l'adresse que tu m'envoies tout ça là
bas et puis tu changeras de ton à
l'avenir s'il te plaît ciao moi c'est
bien il nous reste que 80 château